ai who made billions out of creating
super clunky corporate software
what you didn't realize is that bill
gates doesn't think of himself that way
bill gates doesn't think of himself as
some guy who got super rich making bad
software
bill gates thinks of himself as god in
control of the solar system
and that's why bill gates is now backing
something called sun dimming technology
that would reflect sunlight out of the
earth's atmosphere
causing global cooling
that's not fraught with risks you
thought gain of function research on
pathogens was dangerous
try that but that doesn't stop harvard
university its scientists are testing
that technology
by spewing calcium carbonate dust into
the atmosphere
bill gates is backing the first
high-altitude experiment of one
radical climate change solution creating
a massive chemical cloud that could cool
the earth
it's called solar geoengineering and
it's highly controversial
it would look something like this
thousands of planes would fly very high
and use nozzles to inject millions of
tons of light reflecting particles into
the stratosphere
it would create a thin chemical cloud of
those particles around the whole planet
blocking some sunlight from reaching the
surface it would mimic a giant volcanic
eruption
which we know cools the earth now just
to restate
bill gates is not god bill gates is some
kind of weird
socially awkward rich guy who lives in
seattle he doesn't own the planet
but he's now changing the planet
single-handedly this is not just over
his yard in seattle this is over
your yard and our oceans and the whole
planet
now according to forbes frank kutch who
is the project's top investigator
quote does not know what the results
might bring
i'll just experiment with the globe and
find out what happens it's cool though
he's a billionaire michael
schellenberger is the author of
apocalypse never
why environmental alarmism hurts us all
which it does
as our rivers and oceans get dirtier and
no one notices uh michael it's great to
see you
tonight thanks for having me it's a
little alarming to think that
someone as myopic and out of touch and
totally ideological
and weird as bill gates thinks he's in
charge of the planet
what should we be worried about here
i mean basically everything i mean when
i first heard about this
many over two decades ago this was a
thought experiment
but this is real they're really trying
to do this they've they've encountered
opposition every step of the way i've
co-authored
uh articles with the with the harvard
investigator
we've told him personally this is a
terrible idea the vast majority of
scientists disagree with this
you have to remember what they're
proposing to do is identical
to what we feared would occur after
nuclear war in the 1980s which is
nuclear winter the idea is that you cool
the planet deliberately
the effects on crops are completely
unknown
they call this an experiment but they
know that there is no way to figure out
what the large-scale
planetary effects of this kind of thing
would be it's grossly irresponsible they
know for a fact that they will never get
international agreement
on this so they're basically trying to
socialize the idea
normalize the idea make us comfortable
with an idea that should make us
extremely uncomfortable
yeah a guy who cuts his hair with garden
shears is now trying to control the
solar system
the funny thing is anyone who notices
this that maybe bill gates has
outsized control over our lives is
immediately denounced by
snopes or these fraudulent fact-checking
sites it's like conspiracy nut
do you think you're a conspiracy nut to
have concerns about bill gates hubris
and ambitions
no i mean this is uh this is bonkers i
mean honestly
there are very few people when you talk
to them privately i think this is a good
idea
there's a lot of people that are very
scared to speak out publicly because
bill gates's influence is extraordinary
he's a massive philanthropist i think
his intentions are very good
nobody doubts he's well intentioned but
good intentions can lead to some very
bad
things the amount of hubris and
arrogance involved here
we're talking about millions of farmers
around the world who will be affected by
this
how will they be consulted what is the
idea for how this is going to be
governed
there is no plan for governance there is
no way to get agreement on this
internationally
they know this you know tucker the thing
is the trends on climate change most
people don't realize they're going in
the right direction the united states
has reduced its carbon emissions
by by you know more than any other
country over the last 20 years
we've had an extraordinary success in
the united states in reducing our air
pollution
and now we're now we're faced with the
prospects of this radical experiment
if there's one thing we could do to
improve our country overnight it's tax
tax-exempt non-profits people like bill
gates make billions
they die but they continue to distort
our society with these tax-exempt
foundations we should tax them
immediately
pay the rate we pay today
michael thank you great to see you